it's Monday April 29th greetings from
podcast Ville the church is brought to
you by 23andme this Mother's Day for a
limited time only 23andme is taken off
30 hours of their health and ancestry
kit until May 13th a 23 me health and
ancestry kit is the perfect gift for
Mother's Day celebrate what makes mom
special with personalized genetic
insights on her health traits and more
with the health and ancestry kit you and
your mom can celebrate your genetic
similarities and differences as you
explore your shared connections with
over 125 personalized genetic reports on
health traits and more I don't have a
mother but if I had a mother that's what
I'd be doing you understand me this
Mother's Day the church gets 30% off
23andme health an ancestry kit at
23andme calm / church again that's
23andme calm / church and again that's
23andme coms last Church offer ends May
13th the church is also brought to you
by the goods the beetus my people CBD
lion calm for all your CBD needs CBD
lion is there for you where the vapor
the tensions that the the can the
gummies CBD lion is there for you so
right now go to CBD lion and look at the
third-party test results you're gonna
like what you see I live on this stuff
right now pressing church on the way out
and get 10% off that better yet I'm
gonna give you 20% off your first door
that's how uncle Joey rolls on a [__]
Monday morning alright so go to CBD lion
calm the church is also you brought to
you up again I don't have a mother but
if I had a mother I'd be on point and
send all this great stuff tour this is
something you cannot turn down throw
flowers don't forget to thank the real
pros in your life it's Mother's Day your
mother is the real hero in your life
it's coming up May 12th do not forget
that where would you be without your
month where would you be nowhere
ProFlowers is here to help you show your
appreciation this year right now get a
dozen assorted roses for $19.99 and
double the roses and get a premium vase
for $9.99 more who helps you who does
you like uncle Joey nobody
so visit proflowers.com right now click
the microphone in the upper right corner
right there in the corner and then the
promo code happening
that's proflowers.com click the
microphone on the right corner and use
promo code happening mother's Day is May
12th
so do not wait water like a pro and get
this amazing rose deal to thank all the
moms in your life now I'm still in New
York City I'm still swinging dick but
the podcast is coming at you kick this
[__] melee what's the story
Tammy P your chair dancing I miss you my
brother I know how long haven't I seen
you maybe 10 years that's how long I
know I don't know I think I've seen you
I think we ran into you once or twice in
the store but when I left LA and then
you got do I 2008 at the beginning of
2008 thousand eight yeah I was a [__]
and I was just starting to pick myself
up again I'd been off the drugs for a
year yeah you were doing good and I was
doing okay
at least I was off the drugs that was
the main thing I had got married in
2009-2010 and you moved you had a child
yeah yeah so we got out of LA you know
you wanted to give him a fair chance
live around these [__] Harvey
Weinstein you know Jessie smollett's
yeah my silage the wreck of admissions
you know it's just never Neverland the
man who walked by with a suit no
Superman you have to just one day look
and go what the [__] you know I was in
New York for a few days and I'm driving
up to four or five and I'm looking at
the sunlight and I'm like you know
there's nothing
like this place it's great the sunshine
but you're empty here you're alone you
know well we were the store was my life
that's your life it was my life and I I
love Paulie to death but I saw what
happened when you rate that's because
that's what would happen I'd had my baby
in a bucket in the back and you guys had
been blowing weed in his face but ever
you know what I mean like he would
that's what happened who would burn
comics who watched him while I was on
stage Duncan would had him playing with
that stupid ventriloquist dummy
Duncan used to do that venture they
stole it how do you [__] be George
stolen probably Otto and George I think
I don't want George would that somebody
[__] stole from him after a show
really put it down somewhere what was
his name that thing was the creepiest
[__] well what was creepier is that
Duncan thought it was like he really
that that was gonna be his hook well if
you look at the whole thing
it was brilliant for Duncan just the
fact that go up there take a
ventriloquist dummy put him on your
[__] lap and actually see the people
I mean he let people hear him he was not
even 12 yes no he would do that song by
Pink Floyd wish you were here and then
the thing would [__] him disintegrate
and talk about the devil and satanic
[Laughter]
well people don't have the balls to go
up there and do that first time I saw
even Mitzi sure you know nobody know
what the [__] it was don't know I went
out with him on the road and rogue and I
was watching him I'm like this is pretty
brilliant and even though he knew he was
creeping people he didn't give a [__] no
he wanted it was it was really goes to
that level of uh I can't think of what
his name was a Jim Carrey played on
man-in-the-moon what's his name I can't
think of it right now yeah you know what
I mean cuz it was really like he was
doing it he wanted a reaction and he
knew that it was gonna create a reaction
it's gonna give you a feeling you know
and
some people are gonna find it funny some
people gonna be creepy but he knew that
it was gonna solicit a reaction these
that's really weird too you know when
you use comedy like that like after 10
years you start using comedy the way a
boxer uses his jabs and his you know
uppercuts you know that's why I always
say every art goes to another heart even
us as comics mm-hmm we know what the
homerun is it's the overhead right well
right it's the closer yeah for sure we
know what jokes are a jab and we know
what jokes are body shot just to [__]
loosen you up a little bit then they
suck then they're [__] dropping
checks so we gotta hit with a couple
body shots yeah they don't pay attention
to the 82 dollar tab they're just paying
keep laughing you know you learn yeah
well and where to attack what agitates
what does I know what if I'm bombing and
they don't like me because I said
something that they didn't flow with now
they're gonna get the wrath of God oh
yeah you got a combination I'm gonna
[__] just drop everything that I do
that I hate [__] that I wouldn't even
say in public around my family I would
say around them just for sure okay so if
you're gonna hate me really want a
little dance yeah if you're gonna hate
me let me tell you what's really in my
heart I see you eating hummus omelette
I'm gonna sell you the ten white guys
and I'm [__] you I hate [__] hummus
and I hate hummus either yes especially
[__] Americans weed hummus to be
[__] cute but I take your Isis Ville
and if you like hummus that [__] bet
you know you just go off and they look
at you and they [__] you know you
just lose them or you gain a fan because
somebody says at least the [__] went
down in flames yeah for sure that they
always mess with me there's always one
woman no matter what even still who's
too old to strip and wants to mess with
me in my show and I'm like this is how I
pay my mortgage so you're not gonna win
you're not I not now not twenty five
years in and there's always someone who
tries to mess with you so give them I
mean I always say I give him my out it's
not gonna end the way you think it's
gonna end in your head you think that
you're gonna come out of this cute I'm
gonna destroy you like I want to say
when you want to challenge me in the
middle of the show I know
at first I'm giving you the out but if
you keep going I want to say something
that's so bad that you want to go home
and kill yourself you're gonna stop
everyday and remember me you're gonna
hate me you're gonna light candles from
my death because you're taking from my
son right like this is all I have I
didn't get cast and stuff I don't have
development deals all I have is my stand
up my free speech that I have 45 minutes
to entertain everybody who came and you
can't trick them out of their money
twice right once once yeah you can only
trick people once a night
it's so weird especially today with all
the choices you have for entertainment
yeah yeah and you see your comics that
are going on the road and I'm prepared
and you're gonna trick people one time
you get in you can almost trick them a
second time you get 50 percent because
some people are stupid they'll come back
a second time ago maybe it was an
off-night but it's really weird
especially with entertainment hour the
amount of comics you know last week was
someone like Josh wolf or something goes
I got one of those weekend's again I
know why he was I'm in South Denver Ron
Funches is downtown
Sebastian's at the Paramount Bert crises
at the other theater and then Marc
Maron's there on Sunday he goes I'm
[__] that there's a lot of comedy
there's a lot of [__] flicks so your
game has to be super [__] tight yeah
so when you go to clubs and somebody
[__] heckle you
I have a good presence and I go up there
with a smile on my face so it's very
rare people just get drunk in my shows
and because of the podcast they know you
but I don't give them three cents yeah
but you know that they're not messing
with like even really what happens with
me more than likely I mean nine times
out of ten it's a woman who literally
starts trying to be she thinks we're
friends yeah whoo high five in me when
I'm onstage but she's not getting what
she wants when I'm calling it out you
know if you act like a hole you're gonna
be treated like a hole when I'm saying
the things that are not the political
correct when I say you know this woman's
movement is [__] because we
you take a picture with your friends you
only fix yourself on the face app and
you let your friend hang looking like
Shrek and stuff and then they get mad
and then they're like why aren't use it
and then they'd need the attention and
then that's when it starts where they
start saying stuff or trying to the one
lady I had $20 in my pocket and I said
how much were tickets and they said $20
and I go okay here's $20 for this time
and I borrowed I go through the guy in
the front I go let me $20 and I took $20
from guy friend I go in the next time I
come don't here's $20 to don't come back
the next time not go if you see me on TV
changing channel like I'm never coming
back
good that's exactly what I want you
aren't my audience I don't want you I
want people who get it and have a sense
of humor if I went somewhere like if I
go to a restaurant first of all I'm not
that [__] dumb that I would walk into
a restaurant I don't know nothing about
well let that [__] stupid I don't do
that I won't just try a little things
because oh my god I don't
unless three solid [__] come up
to me I don't walk in there well what's
wrong nothing
you know me saying so I would never
complain like if I get it one Teressa
and I made a bad choice and the food
sucked I paid a guy that walk huh what
happens right now people gotta go home
and Yelp it yeah but I don't care you
know choose so I just it it just
bewildered me that people go out and try
to ruin somebody else's night yeah just
try to go out I don't like I said Tammy
I don't run into it a lot I think
because the presence on stage they were
in Houston I didn't have to throw
somebody out I won't play yeah well if I
won't let it get to plan B I don't let
it get to plan B if I have to look at
you and say stop embarrassing your
girlfriend bro do you know that when I
was shooting my special it was the guy
in the front row that didn't want to be
there his girlfriend wanted to be there
and he was having and the whole time he
was causing problems in the front row
yeah and there was a point in this
special why China did the narrow and the
family saw my future in my feet and I
just saw me
check it up a little job breaking off
you know they would have it on tape I
looked at all this [__] all the
scenarios and I gave him a look like I'm
gonna [__] kill you and then the guy
next to me said something told when I
turned around they were and after that
it was tolerable well that's what's hard
is sometimes what people don't get is
from our position on stage if you're
being a dick I can see the people around
you reacting to that now especially like
my audience tickets anywhere go from
like 20 25 bucks right people don't make
that in an hour some people right so
they got to buy two tickets they got to
get a sitter the baby buy drinks
sometimes there's two drink minimum
there's dinner
they work for a day and a half to come
see my show I gotta honor that because
if I allow some drunken [__] to take
away from my show
they're never coming back I gotta feed
my family right I need them to cut need
them people I know those people to come
back and bring two friends with them
that's what you travel know anywhere
from 4 to 17 days a month depends on
what the I have a nut I have to cover
and that's what I do because I try to
balance it out my kids 11 I need to be
there at his play I need like he's my
priority but he can he functions because
of comedy who watches them when you're a
little mom mom dad my husband yeah my
look is a great day I got a big looking
little look at he's a phenomenal yeah
phenomenal they're like they're like
buddies it's like being at a frat house
very super your husband was always I had
a good last I had let the store you know
to explain Tammy basket I to a lot of
people who she'd be on the podcast for
the first time Tammy and me grew up at
the store we would catch me yourself
Sebastian Bret Ernst you know re
there was just a couple of us yeah and
you were one of the guys you have to see
burn you know you have to it's tough for
a woman to fit in for some reason
everybody is accepted you you're one of
the guys yes you did talk sports yeah
that made your
quite a lot easier yeah well hey I
needed it I think you even gamble
sometimes don't you remember
yeah I got nervous when they made that
movie Molly's game cuz I was the one
teaching all those those big a-list you
know pansy guys I just teaching them how
to play poker is that what you did I'm
not gonna say who but yeah I talked some
of those big a-list people that you play
poker
we won that poker tournament on TV that
yeah I beat all of the celebrities and I
lost and all of the pros except I lost
to the Unabomber if it was like the [__]
the the champion you know wonder why
they call that poker tournament I'm
playing poker yeah well I don't know now
about 20 yeah I just had started a
little bit before but I'm I'm Italian
I'm great at the bluff and then I
learned some skills by playing them the
more you play against people who are
good you learn and so then I started
teaching some of those no personality a
listers who wanted that that was my side
hustle they would pay me to come over
and teach them and so when that movie
Molly's game came out I was like oh [__]
I didn't read had to quit get the book
make sure that nothing was in there
about me because I got letters
everything was above board let's just
say that okay if anybody from the IRS is
listening it was all legal
FBI DEA Rico whatever man doing all the
[__] time I mean it was know you can
learn I was a nap I was a human being
but it was more played out in oceans
eight Ocean's eleven was a Brad Pitt was
playing over in Hollywood behind where
we lived
that's where the game was that's where
they shot that that movie they shot that
but there was a different one right well
this game yeah yeah yeah there was a
different one but I don't know if I
should you know but no no the one that
Ocean's eleven in the beginning he's
playing a poker game with a couple
celebrities no yeah yeah yeah the kids
and that's kind of that that was the
scenario right that was yeah and I think
there was something too and you know we
went through this was they wanted to
laugh a lot of the higher up the
celebrity sometimes they don't have is
they're great actors because they don't
have
personalities to fill the void inside
that they think an act because there's
nothing there to be so they always want
to be around a personality that's loud
and fun and and then we just had a good
time that was good to play poker and but
all of us we were family man I was just
saying to like I remember September 11th
happened I called back home to make sure
everybody was okay and then I was like I
just cannot wait to get to the store
tonight because we had to come together
as a family and that night me you re
everybody came there and then other
people that we hadn't seen in years
that's when Roseanne came down and died
scared like people came down because we
just sat there and there was nobody in
the audience so funny how September 11
was on a Tuesday and that Monday I was
at the store no Paul Mooney came in
no I was sitting watching Paul Mullen
and Paul Moniz talking about how they're
not gonna let no [__] break the homerun
record it was the white dude and the
black dude McGwire and wine and solicit
go home for the whole run right yeah
they kept saying they go with the negro
break the record I'm telling you
something's gonna happen hammer Barry
Bonds Barry Bonds I'm sorry who's Barry
bucks so this is white now everybody
kept saying they're not gonna let that
little [__] keep saying this because
you mark my words
this because that was the last week of
the season or something like that
something was going on I was close to it
was close to it the insane they're not
gonna let that Negro break the homerun
record I went into my head
I don't went home that night I'm
sleeping in the next morning Terry's
yelling oh my god
oh no and I go what's going on she goes
they just tore down the first time while
playing one into it my head I heard
because all the games cancelled that day
I was dying I laughter I'm like [__]
Paul Mooney was right
they even wait they even blew up a
building so they wouldn't let that
like man break the homebody will let you
yeah it was Barry Bonds against the guy
from st. Louis
really it was my choir it was it was a
quiet yes but why do you Barry Bonds
break the record I don't know which I
you know was so funny how think if you
compare the store then to now we were a
tighter bunch back then there were less
of us for sure we needed to be tighter
because there was really nothing going
on down there you know for people listen
to the podcast and all the other podcast
we all talk about the store now it's
packed at this time the store was the
number three Club mm-hmm it was really
there was 10 people it would be 80 on a
Sunday 30 on a Monday 8 on a Tuesday
because it was black playing the main
line huh so white people got the word
out and only the only people would come
in yeah it was it will you laugh the
only people who would come with his
people who were next door it's a hotel
and then now if you had ten people in
the main in the original room on a
Tuesday 10 people you would happy I
remember that hold it off it was for to
start the show and we did you can't have
yeah everybody yeah yeah we'd be after
whatever Wednesday night said be 35
people
Thursday night should be like 105 yeah
you'd make money in your Monday night
yeah no everything else was $15 but then
we went through the no alcohol spell
yeah we sure that stuff on liquor
license well we sure messed up the
liquor licenses so it was no alcohol at
the store for [__] seven weeks people
no alcohol took December 30th yeah could
they have some 30 not get in free think
about going to the comedy story the
[__] gorilla biscuit you go to the
thing you pay selling you know drink
[__] soda I don't even think was BYOB
no no no you weren't allowed no it's not
for seven weeks you had to sit at the
[__] Comedy Store like a deaf-mute
[__] looking at eight comics and
people hate it and the fun there was so
many little things going on like one on
nights I remember Holtzman on stage and
Vinnie favorito took a fart machine the
third
we all sat in the back at the buzzer
I had [__] Holtzman's started going
who the [__] is that
you got stomach problems you know you
didn't know when Mitzi shore was gonna
come down and that was like oh she would
scare the [__] out of it here's what I
remember so Justin only I came from the
improv world
I was already I was like a split week
headliner when I first got to the store
not but people would show up at the club
and and go we don't know who she is but
we already have a sitter like out on the
road but when I get to the store and I
get passed at the store I'm meeting
these guys and I don't there nobody that
I've met on the road but you realized
that this was the place where the energy
was this was the place where people who
were working when you go to the improv
they were doing or the laugh factor they
were doing they're seven minutes
showcase set no industry came to the
comedy store wouldn't even go even if
they wanted a sign here you go
I got a showcase at the store oh yeah no
their food is no parking so you don't go
to the store you could grow at the store
at the store and that's what Mitzi
wanted she wanted you to be able to try
new material and gross she wanted it
like an artist colony so I'll never
forget that first night that I went to
audition for her right and you were
hosting and I was already a little like
I you know the story where I Rick
Messina had called me and said go down
cuz she needs a chick for a night of a
thousand Guido's and she didn't show up
that night whatever was going on so the
next week I came back and you were
hosting again and no one was paying
attention to me you were the only person
who was nice to me
and I went on stage and I had a good set
and Mitzi called me back she was in the
back and she made whoever was sitting
next to where I'm ed or whoever was get
up and she kind of held on to me for
about 45 minutes while all these other
people auditioned and she would speak to
me every once in a while say something
you're good you're really this is going
to be your home I'm gonna and I got up
out of that chair and all of a sudden I
had all these new friends he because
everybody wanted to know what Mitzi said
and and then I stayed up all night and
prayed and lit candles for her cuz I was
afraid she was gonna die before she told
Tommy to put me on the line because I
thought she was gonna die me was that
way before Tommy
oh maybe was don't get you're right it
maybe it was Duncan who was I feel like
it was somebody before yeah that's
always princess Cori she was
what's-his-name's
why are you so those fairies Congress
God rest his soul yeah that was we went
through a lot together that was we
really I remember making a town I came
not a cook but making Italian Wedding
soup putting it together like a pauper
and bring it down to the store so we
could all have something to eat you
remember those things I remember
breaking up with a boyfriend and I had
like a few shirts that I was gonna give
him for Christmas Sebastian and Brett
I'll tell you the story and I pulled up
and opened up the trunk and I was like
get what you guys want pick out because
what was I gonna do it couldn't return
him I got him so everybody got a shirt
and you know we just we made we were
like a just like a ragtag bunch we were
the Bad News Bears how I became friends
with Andrew was because of your husband
yeah because your husband Mitsy past
your husband and he used to take out a
flame thrower on stage a flame thrower
lighter he would put in that black
jacket yeah he would take a flamethrower
and light a cigarette and put it back in
his pocket he he would say he was the
second in command the Gambino crime
family was saying some crazy you know
stage so one night dice was down him he
walked past a thing and he looks at Luca
and his [__] face turns red and I
hadn't talked to dice back then
yeah well ice was down everybody year
and I never said nothing to him not a
word not a hollow he'd sit out there
with his cousin and sit on the step on
the step and then in and I said dice
would kidnap conversation you kill you
if you had a conversation you we still
have to have god bless Andrew but we
said I have to have a signal for you to
come rescue me from DICE it was crazy
but at this time I did not talk to him
so one night second 11:45 I just got
lost stage and dices in the back arguing
with Scott Scott day that your husband
Luca and marina was stealing his spirit
on stage it's not [__] right they
gotta go there and I you know Tyson's
fired me and why do on stage just die so
I was feeling like pressured and finally
had been Scott arguing like so excuse me
for a second language I don't know you
but I go in somebody starts for the
first three years they emulate who their
favorite comic is it's just a match yeah
you'll have different things from Bill
Hicks or maybe a yell likes Kennison you
emulate somebody else until you get your
voice and once your voice comes out all
that skin sheds likely you gotta cut
these guys and pray plus they really
were from Brooklyn and New Jersey and
Italian he's going off he's like no [__]
da da da da and you know what I got my
car didn't argue with him I didn't wanna
start a fight I love dice and then I
[__] the next day he called my house
and he goes you were absolutely right
you know yeah look at it that way what's
your form of flattery
yeah people gonna do it all the time you
know I worked at comics buy the [__]
Saturday they're saying [__]
don't say that but it just comes
naturally just I probably you know it's
just a thing that when you people peel
off on people it's not the kids fall off
it's just that you're trying to find
your voice yeah and that's how we became
friends but I always loved Luca when did
you even get together so yeah if you
know the story really but the fact is is
I never dated comic right no you
anti-cop because i didn't want anybody
to ever say oh that's how she got that
plus I know guys I mean don't forget to
update like athlete shouldn't like that
stuff down there anyways are [__]
around now I'm living in Meadville
Pennsylvania and we're mechanics grow
around Stalin he was I was styling your
hearts and minds but you know I also
would go on the road and I knew that if
I was in a condo because I'd have to go
on the road with two other dudes
sometimes I didn't know them and I knew
that if I dated one that the other one
be like oh yeah I [__] her and it and
you didn't but I could never be able to
prove it like once that goes so I
decided I wouldn't date any comics and
then figure it out from there but then I
met Luka through that stripper colony
that I lived in you remember when I
lived in that stripper colony no you
gotta remember when you came over my
house for a couple parties where I live
behind the dime on North Orange Grove
and I lived in a six unit apartment
building right and it was like me and
this young upwardly-mobile black
attorney and four strippers in various
stages of their careers and I got really
busy that's when last comic came out so
and who else has Mondays off
besides comics strippers so as long as I
had money for dinner I had friends so I
had different groups of it so and there
was all kind of a more of a girl those
strippers cuz I was one of you guys like
you said I'm what was one like I was a
dude I was like Joe pulling the check
you know what I mean I was scratching
balls and everything basically and they
made me softer you know don't you
remember the story I said Joey this girl
just you might have been hide that time
but I I know you know this story because
I was moving into my apartment
right and I'm struggling and I'm trying
to get this thing and then this girl
this beautiful girl comes walking up the
driveway and she sees me struggling and
she doesn't help me nothing she's got
this bag and all of a sudden this guy
comes in the driveway and he's like hey
where are you going and she throws her
bag at me and I'm like what the [__]
here she was like oh I'm helping her
move I don't know this girl but I'm Who
I am so I just kind of went oh yeah hey
how you doing she went off with her
boyfriend and left the bag with me when
she came back I didn't
can open it cuz $10,000 in cash because
she had went with some shake remember
the shakes that used to invite people
over and I told you I told you you said
I wouldn't taking that [__]
I would have taken off don't ever if
there's a bag in your house call me I'll
[__] open it for you yeah so anyway
one of the strippers upstairs was dating
his roommate and they were on the phone
and she was on the phone with this dude
I didn't know and she said what are you
what are you and Luca doing and I said
is that Luca palanca from The Comedy
Store cuz I had never really met him I
was he went home to be with his father
who was dying and I was busy and and
then that was it but I came to you guys
and said when it got to I'm like I'm
dating him what are you thinking you're
like he's a good dude he's a good dude
he's a sweetheart yes we know yeah
always trying to get you in a movie like
the last conversation I had with him he
had a camping movie with the chick who
played the trio yeah yeah he prios wife
Sharon Angela and he had something he
always had something [__] cooking you
know I'm saying whether it came up at
night it didn't matter because he was
always hustling you know and then you
guys got married or you guys just left
but I knew you I saw you I'm different
calendars yeah yeah you always are
different you store on the road and
stuff like that yeah you know what else
I was thinking about I've always been
one of those guys that I want to give
our stage there's really nice comics
that come up to me and say hey you
should throw a tag on this do you
remember the story time basket salad so
for years I wouldn't make tags and one
night I'm up there killing and I get on
stage and Tammy goes why would you say
oh my god oh my god why are you so fat
what am i cutting to cope with butter
and I didn't say it for like a week or
two and then one night I said it and it
got a laugh I forgot all about it I was
dying and I needed something to get me
out of it and I'm saying the joke now
you know you know how I do material yeah
sometimes I do it sometimes I don't
yes and you'll come to me afterwards say
you forgot the same guy no please don't
I was using the joke like that and one
night I'm at the store and I don't know
anybody and I'm doing the joke when I
get offstage an hour later Marty Hoffman
God rest his soul God rest his soul
it was up to me like he wasn't his net
wasn't in his right mind wasn't mad at
this time he was he goes hey I just want
to tell you that I was doing that joke
for a long [__] time and I hope you
didn't see me in Steeler I go first of
all you know anything about me I'm not a
joke to you right I go I just steal it
from you and I didn't say your name or
nothin I just didn't use it I just said
you know what that's what I get for
using attack yeah but I didn't see him
and see I didn't even know him until two
years later so it did so now six months
later I'm at the improv he comes up to
me I don't know a Sunday night guys this
is one that this is when you called me
don't come up to me bro listen I'm the
type of guy that I'm a great guy I love
but don't come out of me out of some way
especially in public he comes at me yeah
a farmer from the mouth and what do I do
to dethrone him I just spit in his
[__] face he kept it in this face and
now they gotta hold him back and I just
point like nobody helped me back you go
get the [__] away from me and the next
time I break your [__] show little
something I mean that this is somehow
dog I was doing major-league coke I was
at the end I was a little pissed off I
wasn't in the mood for [__] games
nothing was happening for me and this is
the last thing I need is this [__]
[__] telling people I stole his [__]
joke from 20 [__] years ago
yeah the guy was old and I got it but
the night he came and I spit in his face
like two weeks later I find that the
guy's got cancer and now I gotta feel
bad about it he had brain cancer so he
was making bad choices I didn't know he
know who did nobody [__] knew so you
know that night he came up to me he was
saying some pretty [__] up [__] and
especially after I spit in his [__]
face [__] crazy right so I go
somewhere one night and there he is with
two goons but the problem was the two
goons he had I saw around town at
different auditions for mafia stuff
uh-huh and the two goons were goons but
paper goons I'm looking on their eyes I
could tell they were weak
yeah papers they must have told him who
I was but not what I look like or
whatever and when the two guys saw me
they kinda like didn't know how to
really approach it like they were like
do we or we getting ourselves well I
didn't know what that deep oh yeah it
did again it got into a bad position I
walked in and I kept it together I go
they come into my space I'm [__] them
all up like I'm just attacking law
career I was still on coke yeah I would
hit him with a bottle I'd do whatever
the [__] I didn't give a [__] I was
taking like a little words and my
brother loose you guys might be stronger
than me about taking I'm taking
something with me so I went I did it and
then I got a call from my agent and she
goes you got a this was when I was with
the comedy agency that lady was Spanish
and she had Trejo and the other dude who
was our friend Emilio Rivera
she had them both and she was like my
sub agent so she calls me up one day
she's like I'm family car fare you're
doing the new [__] whatever movie and
I don't even want to repeat what it says
on the side so I'm like okay it's shot
on a Saturday morning yeah I get there
on seven one who's there Marty Hoffman
with the two goons hysterical so I had
to grab Nick Swanson and tell him listen
Doug I'm gonna tell you this just so you
know I'd be for Monty and he brought
those two dudes if it goes down it's
gonna go down in here probably got you
don't [__] around how do I got like a
pipe and hid it behind my it's my
trailers and then my line my scene was
it Monty I had to sit next I had to sit
next to mine I forgot I had to walk in
with Don Johnson and then take a seat
next to Monty and we had to make believe
like we were friends and [__] was
[__] cruel and then left nothing
happened with the two dudes the two
dudes who look at me to say if I would
make a move and I would just look at
them both and keep walking and then I
heard he died I didn't know is that deep
now what if you remember though it
wasn't when you got offstage we were
talking in the parking lot
and you were saying I can't lose any
weight I'm doing blow all the time you
go I'm [__] all the time I'm doing
blow it blow it out I can't I can't lose
it I let go what are you cutting it with
butter and then you go I'm gonna use
that and I'm like okay that's what it
was it wasn't no it was yeah so wasn't I
never some I don't know Monty Hoffman
you know did he ever call you he did
call cuz he called the night after the
improv and he was like he said that you
gave it to him and I said I don't know
we were talking I don't know that we
were trying to but I go if Joey says I
gave it to him I gave it to him because
I'm not going from you bro
yeah like I'm sorry yeah I said if if
Joey says I gave it to him I gave it to
him Joey's not gonna just say that
Joey's not gonna you know and I could
but it Monty that if that's a joke it's
not no Boca this is my faith he I'm
saying nobody's better than let's face
it I just did I just did now get the
[__] away from me three guys were
holding them the management The Improv
told me to get on stage not to get on
stage they're gonna listen I didn't do
anything did you see my hands get ready
when I talked he came over I [__] he
tried to accuse me I like to hold him
right in the face in the mouth he was
wiping and spitting out of his mouth it
was it was [__] hilarious my god rest
meanwhile I'm at home you know the store
at that time was tough it was tough for
sure you were angry you know you were
getting bumped every night by Eddie dice
all of us yeah Garry Shandling and it'll
go on for two hours you were frustrated
you know you're frustrated you you have
a right at one point you were frustrated
I still know misty but is easy
frustrated everybody in comedy at one
point says what the [__] am I doing with
my life but guess what I'm already at
the store yeah yeah I'm already here
but this is where I always get mad and I
think sometimes it comes on me a little
bit more because I'm a woman like well
someone will say that you're jealous of
someone else's success not is not how we
were brought up our group of friends our
clique every time somebody got something
we would celebrate it I remember coming
after my first Tonight Show
Genet out front all of us together Bobby
Lee we'd get together watch MADtv out
there we supported each other
it was hopeful for us like I said slave
were never upset when one got away
that's how it was for us when someone
busted through that line and had some
success we were always happy for them
nobody was jealous because we were all
in that team together I think and I mean
I don't know what goes on now I think
now because a lot of the people aren't
you know grinding every night there's
social media comics there they're coming
through so maybe there is jealousy they
don't didn't have a camaraderie that we
had I still like them robbery with a
couple people at the store I still I'm
going down there tonight I'm excited yes
well I don't mean just a store I mean
comedy in general in general is always
gonna have complainers you always going
to have people who felt you know people
will tell themselves anything to make
themselves feel better yeah for sure
okay if you want to tell me that you
didn't have a career cuz Rodney
Dangerfield took your career away
because you were doing Rodney
impersonations if that's what makes you
feel good right don't say it if you want
to say that Joey Diaz [__] got you
thrown out of the store and you can now
you can't have a career and that's what
makes you feel good you're gonna say it
none of those things ever made me feel
good the only thing that made me feel
that was knowing I did the work
well comedy solo so really what else has
any influence on you you know what I
mean it's like you're in that bring by
yourself like that it's on you that's
why I think we related a lot to I think
when the mixed martial arts that's the
other thing you and I and Joe always
bonded on because if you remember like
Pat Miletich was a friend of mine and a
trainer for me for a while and we were
that's when the UFC started we were we
were all part of that we all went to
those fights when they first were
starting it was it was hard the UFC has
done what the Comedy Store has done like
it's become commercial like and that's
great you love to see the growth of that
but we related to that because it's just
one-on-one if you fail you fail this
not the audience's fault it's not the
other comics fault if you if you succeed
that's on you like that's your credit
you've worked hard for that you know it
was just a different time well you know
what do you think it is about comedy
that either like you guys are best
friends that like like you look closer
than family or you're beating each other
like it seems like a weird I don't know
if any other industry has that maybe
they do but like what our book how many
does this man tell you a thousand times
as a fan as a comic as a human being
this comic [__] I don't like this comic
so you're like okay there's people that
you like and there's people that you
don't know why yeah and I'll tell you
something else
there's a big difference and here's the
difference now versus then I think this
is my opinion granted I'm old I'm 25
years all monologist you have to figure
out if you want to be a comic or you
want to be famous that's it we didn't
necessarily want to be famous we wanted
the respect of other common I want to be
I wanted to be a comma because that's
one of my problems is that I never
thought past being a comedian right
I never thought oh I should I never made
moves that would have helped my career I
made moves sometimes that hurt my career
because they weren't genuine you just
wanted I wanted the comics to respect me
I figured if I get my friends to respect
that's all you need that that was 49
nobody was giving me nothing
yeah I was only a regular at the store
the my factory didn't want me in there
yeah and he'd probably give me a spot
once a week if that does a black show or
T no Sheldon I didn't I was sleeping in
my car you know I was living off a
Ralphie May in a little apartment all of
us were all [__] given each other
whatever we could it was like oh you you
were in a gang but not really my balloon
busted when the Joe Rogan same went now
that's of my balloon busted as far as me
thinking I was part of something I
always thought I was part of a big
picture I always thought to have look at
Tammy it's like where I grew up
I don't have to explain nothing to you
Tammy you walk in the door and I tell
you to grab a bat you can we go there we
go I don't have to tell you a reason you
know in your heart that if you smack
something the [__] then its they got
a world worth it yeah that's how I was
raised the 3 a.m. friend that's it you
know did you watch the dirt yes I did
watch dirt yeah when he hits that dude
with the guitar just look at night looks
at you this is what life is about what
this is made me I stuck a Parente
Bolzano in the 8th grade and the next
you know it was an Italian house and
they were calling me our favorite [__]
and I was eating pasta you wanted to
stick up for people regardless of what
happens to your career whatever I'll
take the knife has seen ever in that
movie that vent that's the best thing
that a Ben Affleck ever did in that
movie working it no it's the other one
where he's a bank robber and he looks at
he's round the town he walks in and it
goes we got to go do something some
people are gonna get hurt we may get in
trouble and his friend looks at him and
he goes I mean I can't tell you why one
thing went down it disillusioned me for
a long time that was a big that was a
big ghost 2 3 you mean when they they
said don't come back after the car loan
cuz I went to him first
I go something's going on here that's no
bueno Tommy something's not right
hmm and when he was doing that tool with
Eddie Murphy's brother and Tom Segura
they were talking bad about rowing at
the store Tommy and all those guys are
saying when he gets back he's not gonna
do 40 minutes normal on Friday night and
then you have to come to the fact that
at that time it was rope and who was
keeping those doors open for sure he was
all that was drawing that's right I
remember the night he got do you
remember the night that he got Fear
Factor we were all in the back
celebrating because there was it was one
of those nights that nobody was there
and all of us were in the back and just
running yeah in the back well no we were
talking about Sebastian before like we
were a group
once the bastion didn't even talk my
wife tells stories about Sebastian his
shirts how he would come from the four
seasons and meticulous meticulous and he
would have Cologne on he was hanging by
himself he wouldn't say two words we
would go watch him and he would be up
there stiffer than a board huh look at
him today yeah look at him talk yeah in
his dress pants I know it was fun what
about what about do you remember the
time that uh remember how they used to
do the Playboy charity show and it was
once a year and we do big charity show
on the main yeah well they do this
charity show it was just all these
people would pay to golf and a charity
thing and then they'd come to the store
and so the next day they had a party at
the Playboy Mansion and everybody wanted
to go but only me and Eleanor and like
two of the waitresses could go because
they didn't want any dudes to go all
right and that you remember the story
Joey when the one girl tried to fight me
and kicked me off the trampoline this
little that's how I got all those jokes
about the girl that they're mean because
they're hungry you know because the tiny
little one and she literally I tell this
in my act but in real life she kicked me
off the trampoline and I fell down and
like slid down the hill and it's a
reason I'm the reason why they got rid
of the trampoline at the Playboy Mansion
because he was afraid
I never sued anybody in my life but he
was afraid but I couldn't walk for three
days do you don't know and it's a it's a
true story it's tough as a boy this yeah
well you you guys were making fun of me
because I couldn't walk I still wouldn't
miss my spots but I'm like I fell off
the trampoline at the Playboy Mansion
and then and I the joke in my act is
true from what you guys said I go
no one believes you when you can't walk
after going to a party at the Playboy
Mansion it has anything to do with the
trampoline accident so yeah we had so
much fun I used to go to the Playboy
Mansion to do shows with the [__]
crazy dude on the radio I don't know I
said on the radio he's on the Internet
he would do a yearly play Vegas like his
likest
Tom Leykis and I got to tell you
something I think I went to the Playboy
Mansion twice I couldn't wait to get the
[__] out it was so dirty
did I went home and showered both on TV
and I remember telling friends of mine
like from Jersey went to the Playboy
Mansion and I ran out of that yeah I ran
out of that I even got invited when I
was in the longest yard that year
Kazushi yeah Halloween he came to the
set with 20 girls one day yeah he was
you're all invited to my Halloween party
if you want to come so it was a special
Longest Yard Bus and you had to meet
somewhere and yeah and then they joined
me I drove you up you couldn't breathe
yeah you can't just go and I was like I
wouldn't get on that [__] bus if you
paid me of people who you had the chance
to go to the Playboy Mansion you're not
gonna go not in a million years both
times I went it was [__] filthy to me
like I just felt yeah it's something
it's care not about it the other day
the grotto probably had HIV or something
no they just they found tapes or
something having something recently was
discovered about the Playboy Mansion
we um the thing is is that the stories
from the store back in our day we had
all like I feel like we were a bunch of
neighborhood kids that's what we were
you know we were a bunch of neighborhood
it's haunted well that for sure that we
cheered for one of them unborn children
they go taken out by coach but but what
we had opportunities that when I would I
stopped calling home to tell people what
happened to me because they didn't
believe me you know what I mean like
they first of all they were already
thrilled that when I would say it was
friends with Don my rera there'd be like
oh my god you know Dom I read in and
dice I'm trying to get away from dice in
the back thing and then Eddie Murphy
comes in and you know Mitzi's showing me
home movies of Richard Pryor and Sam
Kinison and you just couldn't the
opportunities and the things that we had
were unbelievable because we're probably
that last generation that got a piece of
the legend you know I got a big piece of
her yeah and it's funny her death has
changed me a little bit in the storm
especially my attitude her death me the
dick on the Netflix tape
and her death made me a different topic
I didn't see that it made me go back to
the store religiously like now I'm just
a store comic I'm not interested in your
[__] room anywhere else okay I'm just
going to the store all right I want to
sharpen the [__] knife that's where
you have to go in life is do you have to
follow Ali Wong and louia and Rogan and
[__] run white and [__] you know
you don't really know what your life is
you know and I decided I wanted to keep
my comedy up at that level for me to
keep it at that level go on the road and
[__] lay [__] out bang I
gotta go to the store because I had I
had that my act at the improv and you
adapt your act at the Laugh after it
because it's not accepted to go off the
way you'd go off in the original role
right you know that's a Mitchie sure
taught me that she wanted that's why she
turned us into the soldiers that we are
today yeah that's why she picked us not
for us to pussyfoot PC it none of that
[__] yeah believe none of that no that's
why she ran that place like she ran it
so the only thing I could do now at 56 I
got nothing to lose I was looking for a
job when I found this one right I'm
saying I was looking for a job when I
found this one I'm not 40 I got a sag
pension whatever I want because I worked
all those years because I had the same
problem you had I have you were fighting
at war fighting I dropped the head a
little bit and said then I'm gonna pick
I know my fate I didn't lie to myself I
said I'm never gonna go to Montreal
never gonna do tonight's show
I'm never gonna do Letterman hey I knew
all these things but I'm a regular at
the store yeah yeah so just cuz I'm not
a [__] Army Ranger I'm still a [__]
marine yeah it was great what you guys
did you went around that like I would
have to try to be clean to do the
tonight shows and those all those things
have been little that stuff wasn't gonna
happen so I went to movie route dear
that's great I started booking movies
and TV shows I knew because when I moved
here they told you got a TV show and
weekend when I got it I changed I'm
always the next person and then because
I'm always the person I lose to the I
lose to the person who gets the part
like I don't I don't audition much I
mean I think in 25 years I've had less
than 100 auditions and people who don't
understand in show business that's
nothing you know and I think I've come
close to having the part I've gotten
about five of those parts maybe ten and
I think I probably come close about
sixty sometimes what made you leave what
made you once you had your son because I
needed him to do real truth the real
real truth is that at that time when I
was praying I make my living on the road
I knew that that's the only thing I can
control right like and there was nobody
to show me that that had been done now
Ali's doing specials pregnant Amy's
doing specials pregnant but when I said
I was pregnant my agent said to me I
have never seen a pregnant woman on
stage you better not tell anybody no
one's gonna want a book yeah you're not
with him no more yeah for sure
well he [__] up back I stayed with him
well that's when I said to him I go
apparently never been a really bad strip
club like I was like but it was uh I
knew that that's what I could control
them there had been people at other
levels even now it's Amy and Ali would
they have their they have kids they're
at a better level than I was when I was
pregnant you know what I mean like I'm
I'm a Road Dogg I'm at the club Thursday
through Saturday what am I gonna do with
the kid and then literally a man I'm not
bullshitting you a man walked by me I
was sitting outside the doctor's office
waiting for Luka to get there and a man
walked by me in a three-piece suit a
briefcase and a Superman cape and I was
like we got to get the [__] out of here
this is ridiculous how did how do we
just like you know why not go back home
to Cleveland you know we went to New
York we went to New York and we moved in
one attached house to my mother-in-law
who at the time was insane insane I went
on the road one day
she sold my furniture threw it away not
sold it she got new furniture threw mine
away I had to go buy it back from the
guy next door I mean because she got she
thought her furniture was better than
mine
she changed my son I know this is like
mom [__] but I changed this formula
stuff you don't do to other people's you
know just stay in New York for three
weeks six yeah oh yeah because I was
like look we I said to my husband we had
this house in Pennsylvania I was like
I'm going there when if you want to grow
up and be a husband and a father you can
show up over there if you don't stay
here with your mother and I'll be out
we'll figure out custody and it took him
a couple days but he showed up but I was
like what made you buy that house in
Pennsylvania I thought I was gonna let
my parents live there I thought they
were gonna because everybody was all
separated my brother's one place and my
one brothers were in this town and I had
friends it's a back to the future' town
it looks cute I always want always
wanted out of a small town but I always
kind of liked that small town living
kinda miles to Pittsburgh or Philly
Pittsburgh really yeah so I get in the
car like I had to get here on Thursday I
get in the car 2:30 in the morning
because it's an hour-and-a-half to
Pittsburgh I get up at 2:30 I get in the
car 3 I get to the airport maybe 2 hours
to their part depending on the weather
and I be there an hour early catch the
flight and so like when I miss my spot
at the store that's because I've been up
24 hours by the time it's 11:30 over
here I'm up 24 hours but it's no direct
flights here it's no there are but not
on my airline and I fly so much I guess
what airline has a direct life in
Pittsburgh I think something like Spirit
Airlines or American air you know who
that is my spirit yeah I'm not flying
that I'm not a cheerleader and I'm not
an alcoholic so there's only one Ellen
of lies direct American used to have
yeah everywhere after September they
were
have one one why the day direct yeah but
I try to stay with Delta because you try
to just keep your sanity plus you know
don't say that the time roads so [__]
hell I know no they made it right with
them if they made it right with Tom made
it right with Tom he did always podcast
and like they may hate all lorries means
when I Delta and they made it right they
made it right and and they've been doing
stuff like if I get an upgrade a first
class upgrade I will uh I'll try and I
see that they have an active military I
will trade it out with that military
because you know the military buys seats
for their their people but they're
usually those ass in your face back by
that don't even tilt by the the restroom
so I'll trade with them and give them
the first-class ticket and Delta found
that out and started saying that if I
had a companion and I would say that the
military person was my companion they
would they would allow them to have a
first-class seat so they're trying to do
the right thing for you tell me work of
it you gotta work it well I did thirteen
USO tours those were crazy stuff don't
they do remember the time that I went
over I told you do you remember the time
I was so scared because there was a guy
that I had worked with on the road that
banged a [__] girl for really you
don't know what [__] people did they
I've seen some sick [__] I've seen
people do blow off a sonogram there's
some sick [__] that I've seen and this
dude had banged a [__] girl and it
cost me $17 a minute on my bag phone to
hold it up to the club nurse because I
was like can I go stay somewhere else I
don't want to hear this anymore and and
when I asked him why he did it because
he was married he said because who's
gonna believe her right right so you
don't see him and years go on and you
don't run into him on the road I was a
featurette back then then I go to go
overseas I'm going to Kuwait Iraq it's
right after September 11th that's when
it was quote-unquote wartime it's June
of 2001 and they go they go uh the other
guy that you were with fell out and here
comes this [__] that's the only
thing I could say off the plane and I'm
like
oh [__] I'm gonna die because this guy's
karma is so bad I wouldn't sit next to
him when we would be on the military
plane I'm like it's gonna go down he's
been banging [__] girls so his wife
wouldn't know they're good we're gonna
get hit with a Scud missiles are to go
come to a comedy show yeah yeah she came
to she was you couldn't tell she just
kind of looked slow you know but you
knew something was wrong she was in
pajamas for God's sake like he knew
there were people in the chair he knew
what was going on I this is what
happened I left the show and I said do
you need a ride back to the condo and he
was like no I'm okay and I was thinking
what a nice guy he is cuz he's spending
time with this group these kids that you
know I had said hello to the wheelchair
like you know you he was but I thought
well he must be a nice guy and I was
first time I ever met him and I get back
to the condo I'll not forget because it
was dial-up you know when you had to
have dial-up and I'm on the computer I'm
in the in the living room and he comes
in and I was like how you had a good
show and all of a sudden this girl comes
behind him and I thought and she sat
right next to me and she'd never seen
the compete she's like what are you
doing what are you and he's down the
hallway and he says I see him and I look
kind of look and make eye contact and he
says come here and I start to get up
thinking he's gonna say I'm sorry I
don't know I'm a decent human being so I
thought a normal conversation was gonna
be had like oh she just needed a ride or
a Bubba
he goes no you and he pointed to her and
then the most god-awful Pig [__]
grunting noisy slurpy sounds you ever
want to hear in your life and I'm
sitting there it's already awkward if
somebody else is having sex and you hear
it and you're in the living room but I
know what's going on I know this dude is
married I know that this girl is slow
and I literally I have this bag phone
and I called the you know Colleen
Colleen Quinn from the Omaha funnybone
oh yeah and this is what bonded I go I
go listen thank you now this is a
different day this is nine date I go
he's [__] a [__] get me out of this
guy
come get me let me see your house I'll
sleep on the couch I'll sleep on your
porch just get me out of this condo
I'm not staying and then when I when he
showed up in Iraq I was like I'm gonna
die I'm just gonna die cuz his karma is
so bad that something bad is gonna
happen to us and thank God I made it out
of there
fine you still deliver so toys still
domestically domestically I'm down there
everywhere you go to Huntsville Alabama
you go anywhere
lots of Alaska stuff they're all in
Alaska you go you go up there where they
have a secret reservations yeah I said
we just got to do our own we got to do
what a guy that used to bother me from
the cops Scott Kennedy member Scottie
Canady no God rested addresses so got
you would know that he did is on his own
there was another guy that would come to
when I first got to the store the first
two or three years 97 - maybe
2001 there were people went down there
was one guy used to book Rotterdam yes I
went and I went to that show that Friday
you do Amsterdam is sold out you come
back outside they stopped me at the
[__] County Airport and they were
late ma'am you can't go no oh man me
Jessica Kherson and a Mike I can't think
of that yeah is that the store yeah I
did it was kind of like Oh what are you
doing in two weeks you got a passport
yeah you're gonna answer yeah you're
going to Amsterdam how fast it was no
drama no paperwork no [__] tape
nothing he would just see you at the
store and then there was a it was creepy
- I'm like is this slavery like I don't
know what this is not the contract yeah
but you didn't know if it was real like
until and that was a good news like
somebody went I forgot who went first
you gotta call you long-distance or
something somebody went first and made
it okay for us cuz it seemed creepy like
I'm like we're gonna get over there and
you come back so get us weed this guy
told me a bunch of stories I'm gonna
take of a cafe where you could drink the
THC and the coffee yeah I mean he was
just like my head was gonna blow oh my
god I said and I remember saying I'll
never forget saying to to Ari I go it's
gonna be like that movie the game where
they bring
that's over there to hunt us people we
you think you're gonna do comedy and
they're just gonna let you run and try
to shoot you that's this is what this is
this is the TV show rather damn you ever
got a copy of it I never I there's so
much [__] that we did that eyes that I
don't have I did the world stands up in
London I remember going all those places
by myself being miserable because you
you know you think it's all glamorous
and but you're by yourself going
everywhere and you can't even take
pictures of stuff I have these great
pictures I remember showing my son these
pictures of all these great places but
you're not in them because it's not you
could there were no cell they tried to
take a selfie be your eyeball off to the
side like you could never line that
camera oh yeah she just took one out
night I was watching the episode America
was on the plane she took out one of
those thin ones they used one time yeah
remember the in a flash cube you had to
have a cube crazy so long you've been
doing me for not 25 years 20 don't you
think I should have a better career by
now no you look good oh you have a child
you marry yeah yeah you're not stronger
on drugs you didn't [__] maybe comics
you know you know there's no bad footage
II never said nothing wrong myself at
the straw I mean you have had a
tremendous career listen there's a lot
of women bail that the ovaries call yes
the ovaries come calling a woman there's
not much you could do I'm not a sexist
unless a nice big I'm just telling you
the truth
I've been around Tommy for so long that
you see these women in a gung ho gung ho
gung ho fight fight scratch to thin the
hell today they meet a guy yeah but
that's what it was about it was to get a
man then they stop you stop seeing him
the guy's like a writer yeah he doesn't
want her out doing time then he knocks
her up they have the kid you bump into
in a commercial audition he is later
when she's divorced and going back to
she's telling you that you know whatever
so I understand the ovaries I understand
the need for a woman to come out and be
yourself I mean how many condos can you
stay at and balls can you smell me
you're gonna condo with too long their
feet are out well I got pregnant by acts
I didn't get for I mean God bless and
then my son's not gonna watch this but
eventually one day I'll tell them but I
remember I was in Montreal and I called
the longer you didn't look before you
two and a half years really yeah so we
would live in together and we were
talking about a future and we were you
know but I just wasn't that obviously I
wasn't that girl who wanted to get
married what wasn't my thing always
having coffee yeah no and and I thought
I couldn't picture doing this the way I
did it with a kid because I I know what
I wanted what standards I have for a
child right like I'm not a Filth I knew
I needed to take care of that kid if I
had a TV show or something I could have
seen popping the kid out I would have
planned it but not on the road like what
am I gonna I couldn't figure it out so
but I was in Montreal I'll never forget
this and you know everybody goes out
till four or five o'clock in the morning
in Montreal that we'd go crazy and
Canada all the comics and I was going to
bed like 1:30 and Dom was calling me
going it's won't come out so and so I
was here so I was here and I'm like I
and I said I called Luca and I said I
think I'm I think I'm either pregnant or
I'm dying I don't know what's going on
but something is wrong with me and I
flew in and I got a test and and he got
all excited and I was crying it was like
the opposite of like regular life you
know how people usually dudes are like
oh [__] what are we gonna do and women
are excited I was like I was crying cuz
I just couldn't understand I was 15
years of comic look what's gonna happen
you know it was just different it's just
different time I and I still don't know
how it balances out I still lose time
with my son but I do the best I can by
everybody you know I have sat here for
22 years and saw comics destroyed
careers destroy marriages and destroy
themselves I saw it you know we could
sit here for hours yeah when I walked in
that day and Terry told me I knocked her
up I was ready to jump off a bridge I
didn't know what to think
you know we would just start in the
podcast maybe yeah you're in tiller yeah
I was doing with Felicia I think all we
were doing it already I just didn't know
what to expect
and I haven't been telling her actor at
the habit but she was able once pregnant
dad I don't know what you don't expect
from me as a man I don't know what to
give you a sake I'm trying to be a
[__] comic yeah but the truth of the
matter is at that time
Terry's income was [__] keeping us in
Port Charles
yeah you know I was making a little
money but it was her income together
that we were putting the pieces together
I had because of the drug addiction I
had major loans either alone that was
six thirty a month for six years before
child support before right yeah I can
what was 6:30 every month that's crazy
let's do it and now you have all these
opportunities and it's like I turn them
down to be with my daughter
yeah I don't know I don't want to [__]
the kid walk around Hollywood know what
my kid at the Comedy Store in 20 years
you know unless they want to be right
yeah looking for answers
yeah that's why I write analogue for her
every other oh dude that's good you have
to because if she if I die I wanted hear
from the horse's [__] mouth oh that's
awesome to hear it from somebody else's
[__] mouth you know I have never like
look I never thought I was like a me I
never thought I was a legend we wait do
you know I never thought I was great I
never thought of that but I will say
this that my comedy has never been
better
yes because all the fluff is taken off I
realized that prior to having these two
men in my life you know my husband and
my son I that's all I had was stand-up
that was my life I would talk at people
at night that's why we were such a good
family because we saw each other we
can physically see each other I now
don't care I don't care about Fame I
need people to know me enough to buy
tickets to come to my show I work around
if when when I this one made me lose my
agent this that I worked around it my
priority is taking care of my family and
now that even means my parents you know
what I mean my priorities taking care of
them comedy is the beautiful thing that
allows me to take care of them so I use
it for what it's supposed to be and I've
never been funnier and my perspective is
clear and I think I've never I've never
known Who I am more as I sit here this
moment so that translates onstage I
appreciate when people come and I get to
do 45 minutes an hour and take them out
of their life because I get it
I got to get out of my problems too you
know it's a couple weeks ago they had a
thing that the New York Times put Dave
Attell is the best club comic yes I saw
that and for a long time I'm killed by
the year ago today was kind of struggled
on the road numbers-wise and I remember
saying it on the podcast going guys just
because somebody doesn't have a podcast
or somebody isn't good social media
doesn't mean that they're not a great
comedian right I go a lot of these
comics are on the not on the they're not
selling tickets but that doesn't mean
there's still not deadly comics you're a
deadly comic Jimmy Schubert's of deadly
comic Dahmer Air is a deadly comic this
comic said just because they don't have
a podcast doesn't mean you're not gonna
go support them you might have a better
time but they're [__] shows that when
you have in my show with a podcast no
not your show but but there's that's the
truth
that you guys never stopped you never
stop no you can't say I was my comedy
store trained can you store trained
that's like you know you had intimate
conversations of Mitzi shore she told
you what she expected from you she would
tell you she sometimes she tell you
something that was put the handcuffs on
come on like Fordow cashews they come
out with a glass of wine and just be
like you did a little drunken but do you
remember when she got upset I'll never
forget this I wasn't getting spots for
awhile like it's been like two years and
I was I was Regulus
brought to you know us we and because
nobody was there lien like we got spots
every so you can get to spot tonight if
you wanted sometimes like you got spots
every single night you say okay what are
you home and you got it every single
night she for why wasn't giving me spots
who tried to figure it out and I
remember Duncan were just why she
wouldn't give me spots and she thought I
was that other Italian girl that Julia
Rossi remember her she got confused for
a little bit and because she had to it's
out she had two of everything right
what does Eleanor say it was like Noah's
Ark or something right and she thought I
was Julia Rossi for a little bit and
then I don't know who sat her down to
tell her maybe Eleanor that's it no no
that's Tammy that's not you're getting
confused oh I mean no Tammy I never I
always give comics the respect they
deserve I love watching like I love
going to the store and getting high and
sitting there in the back Mitsy used to
sit
I'm watching the art of comedy and
nobody stops getting funny they get
funnier yeah for sure what you go on
stage you get funnier yeah you know you
said you were dropping a DVD late next
year a specialty but coming up in a few
weeks may third you're dropping out a CD
yeah it's throwback Tammy yeah iTunes
yeah iTunes it'll be you know panned or
whatever you want to however you want to
get I don't even know probably my
uncle's I have it copied in the trunk
you know that kind of stuff
Tammy it's I'm happy you reached out or
whoever to get you on the podcast I was
dying to see you're the first one of all
our group and it made me so happy and I
said of course you were my intro to the
store you would be the first one you
know what do you think about Brenner
it's beginning to kill you one I love it
cuz he's only an hour and half away my
son calls him uncle Brett
yeah we're gonna have some good times
we're gonna have some good times yeah
it's all of it it's a winter buddy
what's even worse though you wanna know
what I really you know I'm going through
now more than anything is that my
relatives are saying to me Sebastian is
my favorite comedian I'm like [__] you
I love Sebastian - but how dare you tell
me that he's your favorite comedian like
you but and then I went I'm like I get
it I get it you got a bow down say
something man I had 20 friends that
called me when Sebastian was at the
garden looking for tickets and my
feelings did not get him no of course
not I told you I was there crying Oh
with you know he's not always going he
was he's been sick and you know but I
went by myself and I got to see him
backstage and he's walking in and I said
to him buddy I go this is just like
walking into the Comedy Store it's
exactly what I said I think it might
even be on his DVD I go but you're
walking into this place the same way you
walked into the comedy store and then he
rose I told you this but I can't but he
rose out of the middle of the garden
with pyrotech and I just I'm standing up
and I was around people that weren't
like the civilians you know and I'm
crying and just tears to come to people
I think this brought his crazy stalker
or something
but just to see that I couldn't just my
heart just a yes I'm at the original
room dying in the back yeah trying to
feel like you're doing it for us like
you're doing it for us like I can only
know I cheer for all my comrade you know
I listen man I like I say every time you
move up I move up yeah I want to be your
wife on something though or your crazy
sister every time I move up you move up
when you're an open mic that guy gets a
special you're friends with that guy you
move up a little bit because everybody
elevates yeah unclogs the jerk nobody
elevates you know so you cannot walk
around with a chip or hating people
giving yourself excuses I'm very proud
of you you gotta be honest thing that
you kept it together you went out there
you built a family you know I mean this
is what being a comic is all about is
growing with the time yeah well look at
the ones who got stale they're stale
this comic sort of stale is still living
all the hills sharing an apartment doing
things that because they didn't have the
right mind to go you know what I did my
time
I did everything I could do let me
borrow here like a gentleman yeah go to
a small town a little money I thank me
so funny you don't say that could still
do my little gigs from time to time you
know that I'm 57 years or what do you
want me to say I'm pretty sick or
anything
y'all might say that I'm gonna beat them
I got me nothing yeah but you use I
won't be able to [__] on the wall they
can never stop that's not two years it's
gonna be a long time god forbid but they
can't stop it like first of all I love
it now it's in my blood there's never
been anything I've been addicted to more
Brian comedy like that's it like I love
the freedom of saying it so you're not
gonna stop me you might not pay me as
much as I feel like I need to be paid
but I'm always gonna work I'm always
gonna work I'll do those mr. Saturday
night gigs to the old people homes down
in in Florida you know if I have to will
remember the Billy Crystal movie I'll do
it all a gin I'll show up in my suitcase
and skate and just stay there and no one
will know but you can't stop people like
me and you who are hustlers like we're
in the good way hustlers like I never
screwed anybody over I never robbed it
but but like you can take away you can
you know you can put a fart on my head
and you can take away my agent you can
take away and the industry can shun me
and drop but you know what I worked
around it I just went and made the cards
I you can I know how to figure it out
you make the calls yourself you go
around it you keep going because
ultimately the jokes will speak for
themselves and as long as people keep
buying tickets and I'm supposed to give
you a good show and I want to give you a
good show and that's you can't trick the
public and I keep coming back to that
but grassroots campaigns aren't allowed
anymore you know in the old days you'd
build and then in the cup and the clubs
would build with you now they want you
to walk in like someone said to me a
club owner goes well as YZ tweeted and
sold out in six minutes and I said well
there's a [__] billion of his people
he should sell out he's a very funny
comic he's been on a lot of things he
should he deserves to sell up but don't
compare me to Aziz that's not that's not
a fair comparison right so you have to
just you just have to know your role
that's that you have to do and I
okay what do you made dates in Portland
at Harveys okay the 16th through the
19th oh yeah I think I'm at a Theatre in
Pittsburgh sealian opal so yes I'm busy
I'm in the first week of May I'm in the
theater and in Virginia
Friday Saturday in Vienna Virginia I
can't think of the name of the theatre
website yeah Pesce Telecom that's it
that's it a good skywriting I have a guy
come knock on your door and tell you I'm
doing that none of your business tour
where you don't don't worry about where
I'm gonna be
don't worry about where I'm gonna be
Tammy
anytime you come out that way you're
always welcome on the show I love you
your family I'm happy if your wife my
love is that baby kicking these
[__] in the ass that Comedy
Store blood and send your best I love
you my brother
thank you very much you filthy [__]
animals and now for a word from our
sponsors yo so I want to thank Amy
pastor tell you that Christ killer and
you [__] for supporting the
podcast always while I'm in New York
City trying to put it together I'll be
around the city this week doing spots I
don't know what nights it but check up
with Dangerfield's I just go in there
and do it 20 minute little workout just
to keep the [__] muscles going but I
want to give a word to our sponsors
don't forget the real pros in your life
are your moms and this and may 12th is
Mother's Day right around the corner do
not forget let me ask you a question
where would you be without your mom me I
don't have a mom so if I had a mom I'd
be sending everything in the world you
understand me as far as my wife's
concerned she's getting 22,000 different
things why because I appreciate it as a
mom ProFlowers let you choose from a
variety of bouquets and vices that suit
every mom style all you got to do is
pick the delivery date then ProFlowers
will carefully package your flowers and
deliver them fresh from the farm express
delivery means her flowers stay fresh
what else can you do for your mother
there's there's no this is the one thing
that they love right now we're gonna get
you one dozen assorted roses for $19.99
double the roses and get a premium vaz
for just $9.99 more with that listen you
can't beat that she's gonna jump up and
down for weeks you understand me how we
start this is you got a visit
proflowers.com and click the microphone
on the upper right corner and then the
promo code happening H ap PE n IG that's
proflowers.com click the microphone on
the right corner and use promo code
happening H ap PE ne ing Mother's Day is
May 12th so do not wait get these get on
this today order like a pro and get this
amazing rose deal to thank all the moms
in your life that's proflowers.com
clicking happening on the upper right
corner and uncle Joey taste Keri you get
the church is also brought to you by CBD
lion calm listen you don't have to bang
your heads with all these stores and
bodegas selling CBDs you don't know what
you're getting today go to CBD lang calm
look at their third party test results
whether you want to smoke it vape it rub
it use the tensions CBD Lyon is the way
to go and it keeps me together do you
understand me so right now go to CBD
line comm and press in church and get
20% off your first order you cannot beat
that you cannot beat that go to CBD line
right now calm preston church and get
20% off your first let's another
tremendous Mother's Day gift when they
cook their arm their back get him some
CBD Lyon duck time right now pressed
Church also for Mother's Day 23andme
this mother for this Mother's Day for a
limited time only 23andme is taking $30
off that health and ancestry kit if mom
a gift that's truly unique with 23andme
how it's an ancestry kid she could
discover how her genes may influence our
health and
125 personalized genetics reports that
feature information on the traits and
health like genetic weight caffeine
consumption sleep movement and more with
23andme personalized wellness reports
she can learn how her genes play a role
in her well-being and lifestyle choices
whether it's our weight may be impacted
by saje already fat or her likelihood
for being lactose intolerant more mom is
sure to discover a whole new way
understanding who she is and you can
share it together you can see who you're
related to what not this is a tremendous
offer so this Mother's Day get 30% off
twenty three means health ancestry kid
at 23andme coms last Church say CH you
are CH that's number two three and
me.com slash church and remember the
offer hands made 13th
I want to thank Tammy basket ally I want
to thank the Christ killing I wanna
thank you guys for bearing with me at
this time where I'm shooting films doing
podcast doing stand-up you're going down
that road with me have a great week this
is the way to start your week off right
kick this [__] meal Lee